[Musik]
hallo zusammen willkommen zu ZDF heute
live schön dass ihr bei uns seid
Deutschlands Landwirte tragen ihren
Protest gegen die Sparpläne der
Regierung weiter auf die Straße
voraussichtlich wird es noch die ganze
Woche Demonstrationen Blockaden und
Sternfahrten geben in ernbach bei
Heilbronn empfangen demonstrierende
Landwirte in diesen Minuten
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ösdemir
zusammen mit dem
badenwürtembergischen
Ministerpräsidenten Kretschmann bei ein
Bürgerdialog wollen beide Seiten
miteinander reden da könnte es gleich
hitzig zugehen erste burufe gab es
zumindest schon ja da fragt man sich
schon
m ist die geplante schrittweise
Abschaffung der
agrardieselsubventionen Ursache oder
eher Anlass für die Wut wie groß ist
insgesamt die Unzufriedenheit im im Land
und fehlt der Regierung das Gespür für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger uns
interessieren eure Kommentare zum Thema
und natürlich auch eure Fragen schreibt
die am besten einfach in den Chat oder
schickt uns eine e-Mail lasass uns
drüber reden mit dem
Politikwissenschaftler und Journalisten
Albrecht von Lucke er ist Redakteur bei
Blätter für deutsche und internationale
Politik und hat schon vom Elend der
Ampel geschrieben ist natürlich auch
spannend zu erfahren wie das aus Sicht
der Ampel gesehen wird das können wir
Karina Konrad fragen sie ist
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der FDP
Fraktion im Bundestag aber eben nicht
nur das sie betreibt auch selbst einen
landwirtschaftlichen Hof mittlerweile in
der dritten Generation und da treffen
wir sie auch heute Abend in Bickenbach
im Hunsrück guten Abend Frau
Konrad guten Abend also wir haben es
gerade gehört ne sie sind Landwirtin und
gleichzeitig FDP Mitglied das geht
dieser Tage ja nicht ganz so gut
zusammen für welche Seite schlägt gerade
ihr Herz
mein Herz schlägt immer schon für eine
unternehmerische Landwirtschaft deshalb
bin ich Mitglied bei den Freien
Demokraten und ich glaube dass wir genau
darüber reden wie Landwirtschaft auch
wieder in die unternehmerische Mitte der
Gesellschaft rückt und wie wir Politik
auch machen für die Unternehmer in
diesem Land das muss jetzt im Fokus
stehen und ich bin gerade darauf
aufmerksam gemacht worden dass ich eben
vom Bundeswirtschaftsminister Ö mir
gesprochen abere ist natürlich Quatsch
es ist der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister der gerade
ausgebutt wurde ähm Frau Konrad haben
Sie sich eigentlich schon ausgerechnet
welche Mehrkosten
auf ihrem Hof auf Sie
zukommen ja die Durchschnittszahlen sind
ja überall bekannt und so ähnlich ist
das auch bei unserem Betrieb auf dem
Mittelgebirge und weil die Belastungen
von den ursprünglichen Vorhaben der
Parteispitzen der Koalitionsspitzen zu
hoch waren und auch unverhältnismäßig
waren im in der Gesamtschau wurde das
auch zum Glück geändert das Ergebnis
kennen Sie ja die grüne Nummer äh die
Steuer Befreiung für Kfz die bleibt und
der Agrardiesel der wird jetzt
schrittweise abgeschmolzen ab dem
nächsten Jahr in diesem Jahr verändert
sich jetzt für die Landwirte erst einmal
in der Einkommenssituation durch diese
Beschlüsse nichts und das muss uns jetzt
aber auch Anlass sein und Zeit geben
darüber zu diskutieren und die Weichen
dafür zu stellen wie
marktwirtschaftliche Agrarpolitik in
Zukunft aussehen kann eigentlich kann
man ja sagen es geht der Branche derzeit
zumindest wirklich nicht schlecht wir
schauen uns mal kurz ein paar Zahlen an
der gewinnland wirtschaftlicher Betriebe
ist im letzten Jahr auf einen
Rekordstand angestiegen im Durchschnitt
betru er etwa 115 000 € pro Betrieb
schaut man auf die Vorjahre geht es den
Landwirten offenbar besser allerdings
muss man auch sagen machen die
Subventionen dabei mehr als 40% des
Gewinns
aus Frau Konrad könnte es sein dass die
Regierung den Unmut der Bauern deshalb
vielleicht nicht so ernst genommen hat
oder oder hat sie das bildigend in Kauf
genommen es ging ja nicht darum bei den
Beschlüssen Unmut in einer Berufsgruppe
zu erzeugen sondern es ging ja darum
einen verfassungskonformen Haushalt
aufzustellen und dabei hat man das nicht
im Blick gehabt und hat das korrigiert
das ist erstmal richtig das zeigt aber
auch dass man nicht einfach darüber
hinweggehen kann dass es Menschen gibt
in der Mitte der Gesellschaft und es
demonstrieren ja mehr Menschen als nur
die Landwirte es demonstrieren ja mit
den Landwirten auch der Mittelstand im
ländlichen Raum der eben seine
Produktionsstandorte nicht mal eben
einfach so ins Ausland verlagern kann
wie die Industrie das kann und deshalb
ist es auch wichtig diese Signale jetzt
ganz ganz deutlich wahrzunehmen und eine
Politik dafür zu machen die weischen
dafür zu stellen dass die Wirtschaft
wieder ans wachsen kommt und das ist
ganz zentral denn bevor man verteilen
kann und unsere Koalitionspartner
verteilen ja auch immer sehr gerne
müssen jetzt auch äh muss jetzt auch
erwirtschaftet werden und das muss im
Mittelpunkt stehen deshalb ist es kein
kein Makel wenn auch mal Geld verdient
wird es muss sogar Geld verdient werden
das gilt für die Landwirtschaft genauso
wie für die Unternehmen insgesamt damit
am Ende auch äh Innovationen und
Produktivität wieder in den Mittelpunkt
unserer Debatten auch Rücken und dann
können wir verdammt viele Weichen noch
besser stellen politischerseits mhm sie
sagen Signale hören darauf reagieren ähm
ist das nicht wieder ein Schritt zu spät
hat die Regierung die Signale hätte man
die nicht vorher sehen müssen müssen
solche Bilder müssen solche Proteste
solche Blockaden erst sein damit die
Regierung die Signale
versteht es ist äh schon schade dass
tatsächlich sich jetzt auch vieles
entläht was ich ja in Wahrheit über
Jahrzehnte angestaut hat und die
Agrarpolitik ist immer sehr stark
abhängig gemacht worden davon oder die
Menschen wurden auch ruhig gestellt
damit dass wieder öffentliche Zahlungen
an sie geleistet wurden man sieht ja das
ist am Ende ein irweg wir müssen darüber
reden wie können Landwirte auch von
ihrer händearbeit Leben und eben nicht
so stark abhängig sein von öffentlichen
Zahlungen und was die Zahlen ja auch
eindeutig zeigen ist dass mit jedem
extensivierungsschritt die Abhängigkeit
von öffentlichen Zahlungen in der
Vergangenheit zugenommen hat deshalb ist
die Debatte doch jetzt umgekehrt zu
führen in diesem Jahr sind Europawahlen
und Agrarpolitik ist Europapolitik das
meiste davon wird auch in Europa
beschlossen deshalb muss das jetzt auch
Anlass sein im Rahmen dieser Diskussion
die uns jetzt bevorstehen darüber zu
reden wie können die Weichen in Richtung
Zukunft gestellt werden in meinen Augen
sind viele Dinge die da in den Vorhaben
des EU green Deal sind tatsächlich
völlig aus der Zeit gefallen wenn man
darüber nachdenkt Produktion zu
minimieren anstatt zu steigern ist das
genau der Fall weg und dahin müssen wir
jetzt kommen es gibt heute die
Möglichkeit beispielsweise über neue
Züchtungsmethoden den den Turbo rein zu
bekommen auch zeitlich für bessere
Sorten in der Pflanzen in der im
Ackerbau wieder zur Verfügung zu haben
aber in Deutschland reden wir viel zu
gerne da drüber ob wir überhaupt die
Straße und den Weg einschlagen wollen
und bleiben am Anfang stehen anstatt uns
diesen Technologien dies ja schon gibt
zu öffnen und sie auch zu ermöglichen
das gleiche gilt in vielen anderen
Bereichen auch denken wir nur mal an die
Chance die auch im autonomen fahren
liegen gerade in einer Branche wo
Arbeitskräfte knapp sind denken wir an
andere innovationsbereiche in der
Landwirtschaft da vieles zu ermöglichen
und nicht auf der Bremse zu stehen das
muss doch unser Ansporn sein in so einer
schwierigen Zeit und es gibt eine
Zeitenwende und diese Zeitenwende gilt
auch für die Agrarpolitik lassen sie uns
konkreter werden das ist auch der Wunsch
aus dem Chat anni hat eine Frage auf
Youtube sie fragt Frau Konrad wie können
diese Weichenstellungen denn genau
aussehen was muss getan werden damit die
Landwirt mit weniger Subventionen
auskommen das ist genau das wo ich
gerade gesagt habe die Produktivität
muss im Fokus stehen es geht nicht dass
man immer bei mehr darüber redet wie man
mit Bürokratie auch Betriebsabläufe
ausbremst sondern es müssen mehr
Freiräume geschaffen werden für
Unternehmer in der Landwirtschaft und im
landwirtschaftlichchen Umfeld insgesamt
und da geht es ganz viel darum auch zu
ermöglichen mal zu sagen es geht auch
was man schafft steuerliche finanzielle
aber auch man schafft auch tatsächlich
vom innovationsrahmen her Freiräume das
fängt bei der Politik bei
Pflanzenschutzmitteln an und hört auch
und hört lange nicht auf wenn wir über
den Ackerbau und neue züstungsmethoden
und vieles andere was innovativ ist
Digitalisierung die Chancen die in der
KI liegen auch für Landwirtschaft liegen
und da auch viel detaillierter drüber zu
reden was bringt das denn konkret auch
für Nutzen in die Landwirtschaft und wie
rollen wir diese Dinge denn in eine so
in eine Branche aus die tatsächlich ja
auch sehr unterschiedlich strukturiert
ist die Betriebe sind ja unterschiedlich
groß aber sagt doch nichts über die
Größe eines Betriebes die Größe des
Betriebes sagt ja nichts darüber aus wie
produktiv und wie innovativ nachher ein
ein Unternehmen auch sein kann und
Landwirte sind am Ende
Unternehmer also ungeachtet jetzt dieser
ganzen Proteste hat das Kabinett ja
gestern jetzt die mehrere Maßnahmen aus
dem Sparpaket für den Haushalt 2024 auf
den Weg gebracht darunter sind eben auch
diese umstrittenen Subventionskürzungen
äh Kanzler Scholz hat dazu folgendes
gesagt wir hören da kurz rein
das ist unser Vorschlag und ich glaube
dass er auch richtig und abgewogen ist
niemand sollte sich Illusionen machen es
schreiben sich gut viele seitenfüllende
Leitartikel über die Notwendigkeit von
Subventionsabbau aber jeder kleine
Schritt wird dazu führen dass man viele
Stimmen hört die sagen aber nicht diese
und ich glaube wenn das die Haltung wird
werden wir niemals irgendeine Subvention
abbauen er sagt ja im Prinzip irgendwo
mussen wir jetzt mal anfangen und m
warum hat es aber dann die Landwirte mit
dieser besonderen Härte getroffen es
gibt den Vorwurf dass
es eben diese Berufsgruppe ist weil sie
eben nicht so sehr zum Wählerklientel
von SPD Grünen und FDP gehört
äh ich kann ihn nicht beantworten die
Frage wer zu diesen Entscheidungen
gekommen ist fakt ist wir müssen mit
diesen Entscheidungen umgehen wir haben
die ursprüngliche Fassung auch abgelehnt
ich habe sehr schnell ähm auch gesagt
nach nachdem diese Beschlüsse öffentlich
wurden dass das so nicht
zustimmungsfähig ist und dass man hier
auch Veränderungen herbeiführen muss
diese Veränderungen wurden jetzt
herbeigeführt und am Ende planbar
Subventionen abzubauen ist auch in der
DNA von der Liberalen agrarpolitikerin
etwas
was auch machtbar ist und was umsetzbar
ist und wo man auch mit rechnen kann und
wo man sich auch unternehmerisch drauf
einstellen kann aber klar muss auch sein
auf der anderen Seite muss auch
ermöglicht werden es geht nicht immer
nur zu sagen was alles wegfällt und was
alles äh komplizierter wird undo W man
noch eine neue Auflage oder eine einen
neuen Zettel erfindet den Landwirte
ausfüllen müssen es muss auch auf der
anderen Seite darum gehen wo man mehr
freie Räume schafft wie man zu
Erleichterungen kommt und wie man
wirklich auch dazu kommt international
wettbewerbsfähig zu sein dadurch dass
wir die Chancen nutzen die in
Innovationen liegen also im
Koalitionsvertrag steht ja dass
umweltschädliche Subventionen sowieso
abgebaut werden sollen in größerem Stil
und dazu gehört eben diese
agrardieselsvention aber das ist ja eben
nicht alles wir schauen uns das kurz
an 65 Milliarden Euro so hoch sieht das
Umweltbundesamt das Einsparvolumen von
umweltschädlichen Subventionen diese
teilen sich auf die Bereiche Verkehr 47%
Energiesektor 39 Land und
Forstwirtschaft neu bauen und wohnen 5%
auf das größte Einsparpotenzial gibt es
also im
Verkehrssektor die Steuerbefreiung bei
kirosin brechte 8,4 Milliarden Euro
die Steuervergünstigung für Diesel
brechte 8,2 Milliarden die
entfernungsparchale 6,0 Milliarden und
das Dienstwagenprivileg 3,1 Milliarden
beschlossen hat die Ampel auf Flugreisen
soll ab Mai eine höhere Ticketsteuer
anfallen der Bund rechnet hier mit
mehrinnahmen von etwa 400 Millionen Euro
in diesem Jahr die Steuerbegünstigung
beim Agrardiesel soll schrittweise
abgeschafft werden das würde rund 4 0
Millionen Euro bringen bei den meisten
Einsparpotentialen im Verkehrsbereich
gibt es jedoch keine
Bewegung also man sieht man hätte mehr
an Einsparungen rausholen können vor
allem eben im Verkehrssektor das ist ja
ein Bereich der in die Zuständigkeit
ihrer Partei fällt warum ist da nicht
mehr
passiert ich glaube die Beispiele die
Sie gerade genannt haben sehen und die
Demonstration gerade zeigen doch dass
man eben auch Politik mit den Menschen
machen muss und den ländlichen Raum
nicht aus dem Blick verlieren darf denn
am Ende müssen die Leute mobil sein und
wenn Subvention abgebaut wird dann
werden dann muss das auch einhergehen
mit Kompensation denn am Ende müssen die
Leute mobil bleiben man muss auch eine
Antwort auf die Frage finden wie die
Menschen mobil bleiben im ländlichen
Raum und dass man diesen Weg jetzt
gefunden hat und ich sag mal auch in
einer Nachverhandlung zu einem
Kompromiss kam der die Landwirtschaft
jetzt trifft das muss dazu führen dass
in der Landwirtschaft tatsächlich auch
Kompensation stattfindet aber wir
brauchen insgesamt wieder mehr Wachstum
auch in der im ländlichen Raum damit
Arbeitsplätze erhalten werden und die
Menschen auf dem Land genauso beteiligt
werden am Leben wie die Menschen in der
Stadt das ist ja auch das Gefühl was
gerade bei diesen Demonstration um sich
greift und daher halte ich nichts von
abstrakten Debatten über pauschale
Kürzungen sondern wir müssen tatsächlich
bei Entscheidungen auch beachten was hat
das tatsächlich auch für Auswirkungen
nachher auf die Menschen es trifft ja
meistens die die wenig Geld im
Geldbeutel haben Norbert hat hier zu
eine Nachfrage im Chat er fragt warum
schafft man nicht das
Dienstwagenprivileg ab ist es mit der
FDP nicht zu machen und man lässt dafür
die Bauern
bluten ich höre immer wieder ganz oft
dass es ein Dienstwagenprivileg gäbe in
Wahrheit ist das ja eine
bürokratieverereinfachung dass man auf
das fartenbuch verzichtet und deshalb
eine pauschale hat auf der anderen Seite
und solche pauschalen die erleichtern
vieles die wir treffen nie 100% die
belasten manche Menschen stärker manche
nutzen das Auto mehr als als die 1%
privat mal andere weniger aber damit hat
man einen Weg gefunden auch Bürokratie
zu sparen das spart Bürokratie auf
staatlicher Seite weil man auch nicht
alles kontrollieren muss und das
vereinfacht es den Menschen von daher
würde mich mal tatsächlich interessieren
was da konkret gemeint ist wenn man
immer pauschal da drüber redet wen man
jetzt vereinfachungsmechanismen
abschaffen das ist auf jeden Fall kein
geeigneter Weg also man hört ganz klar
Einsparung im Verkehrssektor sind
derzeit kein Thema für Sie den noch ist
es ja so dass FDP Parteichef und eben
auch Finanzminister Lindner sich ja im
Dezember mal ganz offen gezeigt hatte
für die Rücknahme der Streichung der
Agrar dieselsubventionen
warum ist da dann nichts passiert hat
die FDP keine Alternativen
gefunden es ist ja etwas passiert das
stimmt ja nicht was sie sagen es ist ja
etwas passiert es waren ja zwei
Kürzungen auf einmal im Gespräch das
hätte fast eine Milliarde für die
Landwirtschaft alleine ausgemacht das
ist völlig unf von Rücknahme der
Subventionen gesprochen und deshalb und
deshalb musste man das ändern man muss
aber dann auch auf der anderen Seite
Einsparpotenzial im Haushalt finden denn
das ist auch klar wir brauchen solide
Haushalte wir müssen jetzt einen
verfassungskonform Haushalt am Ende auch
beschließen und mir ist es ganz wichtig
dass bei all dem was jetzt diskutiert
wird und auch bei dem gefundenen
Kompromiss klar ist dass jetzt hier eine
Härte entstanden ist es wird eine
Subvention abgebaut das ist immer
erstmal kein schlechter weg aber wird
eine Branche belastet die jetzt zurecht
sagt dann brauchen wir aber auch
Vereinfachungen an anderer Stelle und
diese Vereinfachungen können nicht
dadurch gehen dass man wieder Geld nimmt
und mit der giekanner ausschüttet
sondern diese Vereinfachungen müssen
dadurch gehen dass man Bürokratie abbaut
Innovationen ermöglicht und die
Produktivität steigert da würde ihnen
auch Stefanie auf Facebook Recht geben
sie schreibt das Problem beim Handwerk
und eben auch bei der
landwirtschaftlichkeit Landwirtschaft
ist der Bürokratismus der mit der Ampel
inzwischen aber auch massiv ausgeb baut
wurde
Frau Konrad Finanzminister Lindner
besteht ja weiter auf der Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse macht es aus ihrer Sicht
noch Sinn bzwise ist diese Haltung dann
jetzt auch noch
zeitgemäß nicht Finanzminister Lindner
besteht auf die Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse sondern die ist Teil
unserer Verfassung und am Ende müssen
wir mit dem Geld auskommen was die
Bürger haben wir haben übrigens höchst
Steuereinnahmen es ist ja nicht so als
würden wir in irgendeiner Art und Weise
am Hungertuch lagen aber natürlich hat
das
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts einiges
durcheinander gewirbelt und äh hat dafür
gesorgt dass man jetzt auch priorisieren
muss ähm und tatsächlich auch sich
dieser Herausforderung stellen muss und
ich glaube dass das jetzt die Aufgabe
ist der Ampel das in Zukunft auch
geräuschloser zu tun und auch mit etwas
mehr Weitblick das sage ich auch sehr
selbstkritisch an der Stelle dass man
mit mehr Weitblick tatsächlich auch in
die Dinge reingeht und am Ende auch mit
Entscheidungen dabei rauskommt die
tragbar sind die machtbar sind und die
auch umsetzbar sind und und die am Ende
dazu führen dass unsere Wirtschaft
wieder ans wachsen kommt da drauf kommt
es jetzt an wir sind in einer
schwierigen Zeit es sind viele Umbrüche
der lindner selbst sprach ja bei drei
König von epochenbrüchen und das ist ja
auch etwas was die Menschen umtreibt was
die Menschen auch verunsichert was ihnen
Angst macht und in so einer Zeit
tatsächlich auch Stabilität zu bilden
dadurch dass wir unsere Staatsfinanzen
im Griff behalten das ist doch das ist
nicht trivial sondern das ist dringend
notwendig mm mm ich habe noch eine
letzte Frage an Sie
das ist ein Kommentar aus dem Chat mit
der Bitte um eine ebenfalls
selbstkritische Antwort wie sie gerade
gesagt haben Kai Herder fragt auf
Facebook bzw schreibt auf Facebook das
sind keine bauernproteste es sind
Bürgerproteste es geht nicht nur um
subpensionen es geht in erster Linie
gegen die Ampel deshalb auch die hohe
Akzeptanz für die Bürgerprotest
bauernproteste Frau Konrad hat ihre
Ampel ein Gespür dafür versteht sie noch
was die Menschen im Land
umtreibt
ich glaube dass viele falsch
informformationen unterwegs sind und
dass ähm wenn wenn ich die Selbstkritik
fortführen darf dass die Ampel lernen
muss ihre Ergebnisse auch ähm den
Menschen besser zu erklären denn es gibt
durchaus große Erfolge die im Sinne
aller Bürgerinnen und Bürger sind wenn
ich nur mal daran erinnern darf welche
Beschlüsse wir jetzt auch in der
Migrationspolitik auf den Weg gebracht
haben um eine geordnete Migration zu
ermöglichen was vom Schutz der EU
Außengrenzen über den Grenzschutz in
Deutschland bis hin zur schiebehhaft und
auch ähm den den Kürzungen von
Leistungen beim Bürgergeld geht was dazu
führt dass wir tatsächlich auch wieder
eine neue Leistungsgerechtigkeit
ansporen darum geht es ja auch vielen
Menschen die unterwegs sind wenn man mal
genau hinhört geht es ja auch um das
Gefühl dass Leistung sich nicht mehr
lohnt das Gegenteil ist der Fall und da
wage ich auch mal neuen Optimismus
leistung lohnt sich und dafür sorgen wir
als FDP und da trhen wir auch da kämpfen
wir auch jeden Tag aufs Neue für auch in
dieser Koalition und deshalb kann ich
nur sagen wir dürfen nicht verzagen ja
die Zeiten sind schwierig
aber diese Koalition ist und muss auch
dazu in der Lage sein in diesen
schwierigen Zeiten dieses Land zu
regieren und es den Menschen auch zu
erklären und sie mitzunehmen damit sie
nicht verrückt gemacht werden von
Menschen die im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes im eigentlichen Sinne dieser
Demokratie gar nichts Gutes wollen und
nur die Menschen für ihre eigenen Zwecke
instrumentalisieren um sie wütend zu
machen um ihnen Angst zu machen und
ich bin freier Demokrat weil ich auch
Optimist bin und ich glaube das Glas ist
nicht halble leer es ist halb voll aber
es liegt an uns wie wir damit umgehen
und ich danke Ihnen ganz herzlich für
das Gespräch und danke auch dass sie so
lange in der Kälte ausgehalten haben
machen sie es gut Frau Konrad
tschüss machen sie es gut vielen Dank ja
soweit eine Stimme aus der Regierung wir
wollen jetzt mit dem Journalisten und
Politikwissenschaftler Albrecht von
Lucke sprechen der mit Sicherheit gerade
sehr genau zugehört hat was Frau Konrad
gesagt hat guten Abend Herr von Lucke
guten Abend Frau zahidi also die
Experten sind sich ja weitgehend einig
die Kürzung der
dieselbeihihilfen ist vielleicht
schmerzhaft aber verschmerzbar warum ist
der Aufschrei denn dann trotzdem so groß
hat die Ampel den Rückhalt in der
Bevölkerung
verloren na ja zunächst muss man
feststellen und das machte den Aufschrei
aus dass vor allem eine Sparte zentral
getroffen war das war die Bauernschaft
also die Landwirtschaft aber und das ist
auch schon hier der entscheidende Punkt
in Kommentierung dessen was ich jetzt ja
genau verfolgt habe genau wie sie es
gesagt haben die Bauernschaft ist
hochgradig gespalten das Problem besteht
darin dass natürlich es durchaus
berechtigt ist Subventionierung
zurückzustreichen wir müssen uns bewusst
machen gerade wenn Frau Konrad immer
davon sprach dass mehr Marktwirtschaft
einzuhalten muss dass die Bauernschaft
1% zum Bruttosozialprodukt beiträgt aber
4 % an Subventionen erhält und es ist so
und das ist der fatale Fehler die
Subventionen kommen allein der Größe
zugute das heißt ein gut ein ein Hof mit
äh 1000 2000 Hektar es gibt derartige
Höfe ja mittlerweile längst gerade im
Osten wo sehr viel zusammengekauft wurde
dieser Hof kriegt maximale
Subventionierung obwohl er
möglicherweise nicht in dem Maße Einsatz
von Personen betätigt und auch
ökologisch gar nicht nützlich ist
während kleinere Höfe mit großem Aufwand
sehr viel weniger subventioniert werden
und deswegen ist genau an dem Punkt zu
sagen das Problem bestand darin dass die
Ampel das nicht erklärt hat man konnte
den Eindruck haben und das hat auch der
Bauernverband das hat auch V Konrad in
der gleichen Argumentation stark gemacht
man konnte den Eindruck machen alle
werden gleichermaßen getroffen dabei
sind es vor allem die kleineren Bauern
die natürlich stärker getroffen sind
wenn der Diesel teurer wird oder auch
die KFZ Pflicht kostenpflichtig wird und
keine Befreiung existiert es kommt aber
zentral darauf an deutlich zu machen
dass gerade die großen in einem Übermaß
subventioniert werden und wenn man
wirklich Marktwirtschaft einhalten will
dann müsste man an diesen großen
Subventionen ran dann müsste man nicht
mehr äh letztlich für Masse
subventionieren allein dafür die
Tatsache wer wie viel Hektar hat kriegt
dann pauschal dementsprechend Subvention
das ist Grund falsch und da müsste man
mer mehr Marktwirtschaft einführen das
hat aber die Ampel leider nicht
hinreichend erklärt und deswegen bricht
sich jetzt der Protest an dieser
Maßnahme sie sagen nicht hinreichend
erklärt das ist ja jetzt nicht die erste
Situation denken wir an das
heizungsgesetz oder den Streit über die
Kindergrundsicherung oder eben jetzt der
Streit über den Haushalt
ist das schlechte Kommunikation oder
muss man mittlerweile auch sagen da
gibt's einige die machen ihren Job
einfach schlichtweg nicht gut ja in der
Tat es ist schlechtes regieren man muss
es sehr deutlich sagen und dieses
schlechte regieren hat einen zentralen
Grund dieser Protest der jetzt in der
Bevölkerung aufkommt und der geht ja
weit über die Bauernschaft hinaus wir
erleben gerade dass die
Logistikunternehmen also die
Fuhrunternehmen sich anschließen dass
sie mitdemonstrieren es sind Handwerker
die mitdemonstrieren das ist vor allem
einem Umstand geschuldet diese Ampel hat
es von Anfang an nicht vermocht deutlich
zu machen eine gemeinsame Linie zu
finden es ist ironischerweise so dass
der Klientelismus in der Ampel der
übrigens sehr stark auch von der FDP
provoziert wurde wir haben es ja auch
bei Frau Konrad gehört die Ampel hat
sich ein Stück weit regelrecht als
Opposition in der Regierung geriert also
Oppositionspolitik gegen die beiden
anderen Parteien gemacht in Verteidigung
ihrer klientelinteressen beispielsweise
was den Verkehrssektor anbelangt auf den
sie ja abgestellt haben keine Einführung
von Tempo Limbo 130 kein Dienst Wagen
Privileg Abschaffung all das sind Punkte
bei denen ganz klar die FDP sehr stark
Klientelpolitik gemacht hat die Grünen
das muss man ihnen auch vorwerfen haben
auch in Teilen ihre eigene Klientel
bedient sie waren nicht immer im
gemeinwoh Interesse unterwegs und ein
Kanzler hat zu alle dem geschwiegen und
dieser Umstand dass die Bevölkerung
nicht erkennt dass insgesamt die
allgemeine der allgemeine Wille bzw das
gesamtgesellschaftliche Interesse im
Mittelpunkt steht das führt dazu dass
diese nicht konzertierte nicht
geschlossen agierende Regierung jetzt
bei der Bevölkerung quasi
spiegelbildlich auch den Prozess
hervorruft wenn Einzelinteressen nur im
Mittelpunkt des regieren stehen dann
werden diese einzelinessen auf der
Straße mobil machen und genau das
erleben wir jetzt und das ist so
dramatisch weil man den Eindruck hat
möglicherweise kann die Ampel irgendwann
ihre Projekte gar nicht mehr durchsetzen
wenn sie letztlich im Endeffekt
möglicherweise sogar alles zurücknimmt
deshalb ist es so entscheidend dass
gerade gegenüber den Bauern jetzt
wenigstens dieser Restbestand der
Kürzung geringfügig gestreckter Kürzung
der Subvention im Bereich der
dieselsubventionierung dass wenigstens
das aufrecht erhalten wird anderenfalls
wird die Regierung recht erpressbar denn
dann wird jeder andere klientelgruppe
sagen wir demonstrieren nur wir machen
die Straße mobil dann werden wir schon
sehen dass auf Maßnahmen die gegen uns
getroffen werden wieder zurückgenommen
werden dazu schreibt music Freak die FDP
hat sich total verrannt und muss jetzt
leider diesen Weg weitergehen sie sagen
es ist jetzt ganz wichtig dass es auch
durchgezogen wird diese Kürzung
aber jetzt fordern ja auch die
regierungschefinnen von megcklenburg
Vorpommern und aus dem Saarland und auch
der Ministerpräsident von Niedersachsen
das wieder zurückzunehmen also auch
innerhalb einer Regierungspartei rumort
es ja ordentlich ja und das halte ich
für absolut fatal wir haben auch andere
Stimmen Manuela Schwesig hält diese
Position aufrecht die sie genannt haben
Herr weil auch wie Sie gesagt haben das
sind natürlich die Länder die besonders
viel Landwirtschaft haben aber Frau
Dreier beispielsweise die in
reinlandfalz auch viel Landwirtschaft
hat hat erkannt dass wenn man jetzt an
dieser Situation
auseinanderbricht und auch diese man
muss es wirklich deutlich sagen es geht
hier ja nicht um gro gr Subventionierung
die sofort abgeschafft würden es geht um
die streckende schrittweise Abschaffung
des dieselprivilegs der
dieselsubventionierung wenn man das
jetzt auch noch kippt dann bleibt nichts
von der Entscheidung der Bundesregierung
und dass diese drei Länder auch der SPD
geführten Länder jetzt der eigenen
spdregierung quasi in den Rücken fallen
ist desaströs weil am Ende haben wir es
mit einer ohnmächtigen Bundesregierung
zu tun und das kann in keiner
in keines Interesse sein das wäre fatal
dann müsste man sich fragen was diese
Regierung eigentlich noch die nächsten
zwei Jahre durchsetzen will genau und
ähm diese Frage müssen wir uns
tatsächlich stellen denn die Regierung
ist ja wirklich damals mit dem Vorhaben
gestartet das Land in einen neuen
Aufbruch zu führen und das ist bis jetzt
nicht gelungen warum ist es nicht
gelungen stehen die sich selbst im Weg
oder wie Stefan leibach auf Youtube
fragt hat die Regierung eben auch das
Vertrauen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
verspielt ja sie hat es in einem
gewaltigen Maße verspielt und das große
Problem jetzt da wir ja gerade erst nach
der Halbzeit sind und stehen noch
eigentlich zwei Jahre des Regierens
bevor das große Problem ist dass das was
in zwei Jahren verspielt wurde an
Vertrauen dadurch verspielt wurde dass
man nicht geschlossen agiert hat
wie ich es beschrieben habe eine Ampel
die ständig nur als Kakophonie agiert in
der die eine Partei aus dem Prinzip
heraus sich gegen zwei andere Parteien
die sie als links beschreibt während sie
selber wirtschaftsliberal sein will die
FDP die sich primär als Opposition
darstellt und meint sie könne sich
dadurch profilieren aber dadurch das
ansehen in der gesamten Ampel nach unten
zieht während auch beispielsweise die
Grünen große kardinale Fehler gemacht
haben und ein Kanzler nicht geführt hat
eine Ampel die jetzt nach zwei Jahren so
viel schlechter darasteht hat natürlich
jetzt allergrößte Probleme geschlossen
aufzutreten wir sehen ja die neuen
Probleme bereits am am Horizont die FDP
verteidigt mit Zeh und Clown Zeh und
Clown die schwarze Null die
Schuldenbremse es gibt auch kein not
fall bzw man könnte ja drüber
diskutieren ist die Flut möglicherweise
ein Grund um zu sagen wir haben wieder
eine veritable Krisensituation oder was
ja bereits angedeutet wurde wird
möglicherweise der Krieg in der Ukraine
so dramatisch dass die Bundesrepublik
sich doch in größerem Maße verschulden
muss all dem Gegenüber sagt die FDP niet
und das ist schon der nächste Konflikt
der sich auftut während SPD und Grüne
nämlich fordern wir brauchen mehr
Investitionen das heißt die FDP
verteidigt hier weil sie Angst hat vor
dem eigenen Untergang weil sie ihr
Alleinstellungsmerkmal die schwarze Null
Solidität der K Kassen zu verteidigen
hat deswegen stellt sie sie sich gegen
SPD und Grüne aus einem ja rationalen
Grund man kann das verstehen sie hat
Angst dass sie bei den nächsten Wahlen
abstürzt aber auf diese Weise wird die
Zerstrittenheit der Koalition
perpetuiert sie wird fortgesetzt und das
wird dazu führen dass der Protest weiter
zunimmt und am Ende wir erleben es ja
jetzt seit zwei Jahren der
Rechtspopulismus im Lande weiter wächst
dazu gibt's noch eine Frage von Herr
science auf Youtube ähm eine spannende
Frage wie ich finde er schreibt da viele
Proteste Kritik oft direkt als rechts
bezeichnet werden sinkt dann eventuell
die Hemmschwelle für normale Bürger sich
rechten Protesten anzuschließen da ja
dann eh alles rechts ist das in der Tat
ich halte das auch für völlig falsch man
es macht keinen Sinn diese Proteste von
Bauern als rechts zu beschreiben es gibt
natürlich den Versuch das muss man
deutlich erkennen wenn beispielsweise in
Sachsen die freien Sachsen eine
ausgesprochen rechtsradikale Gruppierung
bei den Demonstrationen mitzieht sie zum
Teil unterwandert es gibt versuche diese
Proteste zu instrumentalisieren das
Problem ist aber ein ganz anderes das
Problem ist dass eine Gruppe wie die
Bauern die ja eigentlich klassisch
konservativ sind die tatsächlich meist
beharlich sind also eher darauf achten
dass ihre Bestände auch gewahrt werden
dass sie Gefahr laufen letztlich
jeglichem Fortschritt den sie zum Teil
bereit waren mitzugehen dass sie diesem
apphollt werden dass sie dem abschwören
wenn der Eindruck entsteht das wird
nicht geschlossen und klar kommuniziert
das ist das große Problem also eine
versagende Regierung eine zerstrittene
Regierung produziert regelrecht aus sich
heraus den Widerspruch das reaktionäre
und das ist natürlich fatal wenn man
eigentlich und das ist ja die große
Herausforderung nach wie vor ein Land
transformieren muss in eine nachhaltige
ökologische Zukunft das ist die
eigentliche h große jahrhundertaugabe
und das betrifft nicht zuletzt die
Landwirtschaft die weit stärker
nachhaltig werden muss kleinteiliger
eben nicht wie es Frau Konrad sagte
immer nur dem Mittel der Produktivität
des Wachstums unterworfen sonder sondern
ganz andere Aufgaben auch vertreten muss
Ökologie Landschaftsschutz und
dergleichen das sind Aufgaben die
wichtig sind aber das muss man auch
deutlich sagen die natürlich auch uns
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dann in die
Pflicht nehmen mehr Geld für
Lebensmittel auszugeben also Herr von
Lucke letzte Frage an Sie was muss denn
jetzt passieren damit die Ampel noch mal
neu durchstarten kann gerade im Hinblick
auf die Sorgen und Nöte der Bevölkerung
es stehen Wahlen an in drei ostdeutschen
Bundesländern die AFD ist nach wie vor
im Aufwind oder wie Pogo fragt steht
denn Hoffnung auf Besserung der
Ampel ja das will glaube ich jeder von
uns hoffen der ein Interesse daran hat
dass die Rechtspopulisten nicht durch
die Decke gehen und wir eines Tages wir
haben ja im Herbst vor allem die drei
Wahlen in Ostdeutschland dass wir nicht
eine blaue Welle erleben das heißt die
Voraussetzung das zu verhindern ist ein
konzertiertes klares gemeinsames
geschlossenes Agieren der Ampel die auch
dann dafür Sorge tragen muss dass nicht
jeder Beschluss sofort wieder aufgemacht
wird aber leider muss ich auch hier
Wasser in den Wein gießen denn genau
dieses Problem dass gerade weil die drei
Parteien sich so runtergewirtschaftet
haben dass sie jetzt umso mehr auf ihre
eigene Profilierung schauen werden
dieses Problem spricht eher dafür dass
der schreit noch größer werden wird und
dass wir also insofern es weiter mit
einer Ampel zu tun haben werden die eben
nicht geschlossen agiert und das wird
leider den Rechtspopulismus weiter
wachsen lassen düstere Aussichten Herr
von Lucke ich danke Ihnen sehr für ihre
Analyse und ihre Einschätzung machen sie
es gut tschüss Ihnen einen schönen Abend
danke danke ciao
ja und damit danke ich auch euch fürs
zuschauen eure Fragen und eure
Kommentare das war ZDF heute live bis
bald
tschüss